Кордони для туристів поступово відкриваються.
З 1 липня українці зможуть потрапити на турецькі пляжі.
Саме тоді офіційна Анкара обіцяє відновити регулярні пасажирські перевезення з Україною
та створити всі умови для безпечного відпочинку.
Туристичні яхти, басейни та готелі
вже зараз активно дезінфікують і готують до прийому туристів.
У липні минулого року Туреччина для українців була
безумовним лідером серед країн літнього відпочинку.
За даними туроператорів, на цю країну припадало 45% заброньованих путівок.
Турецька економіка, своює чергою, суттєво залежить від туризму.
За офіційними даними, минулий рік був дуже вдалим:
туризм зріс на 14 відсотків
і країну відвідали понад 45 мільйонів іноземних туристів.
Найпопулярніші - Стамбул та курорти Анталії.
Нині ж готелі та крамниці через пандемію коронавірусу
та карантинні заходи підраховують збитки
і сподіваються хоч якось врятувати цьогорічний турсезон.
Коротка молитва, і ворота до легендарного "Гранд-базару" в Стамбулі відкриті.
Цей ринок, який до коронакризи щодня відвідували близько 150 тисяч людей,
був закритий понад два місяці -
найдовше за півтисячолітню історію "Гранд-базару".
Нині на всіх входах до ринку перевіряють температуру.
Обов’язково потрібно носити маски, а кількість клієнтів у магазинах обмежена.
Перші відвідувачі дуже раді, що ринок нарешті знову працює.
Добре, що його знову відкрили. Ми цього чекали.
Я зроблю кілька покупок, а потім знову поїду додому.
Вперше за довгий час я знову вийшла на вулицю.
Торговці прибирають свої магазини.
Вони теж радіють, хоча й не очікують суттєвого виторгу найближчим часом.
Продавець килимів Кемаль розповідає, що найважливіших клієнтів ще немає.
Для нас важкі часи.
Туристичний сезон ще не розпочався через кризу.
Міжнародні рейси до Туреччини, як кажуть,
відновляться до середини червня.
Але ми не знаємо, скільки туристів насправді приїде.
Мене це непокоїть.
Поза межами ринку крок за кроком послаблюють карантинні заходи.
Багато мечетей вже відкрито для масових зібрань.
Але через правила соціального дистанціювання
багатьом віруючим доводиться молитися на вулиці.
Ця найбільша торгова вулиця Стамбула - Істікляль -
була безлюдною під час карантину.
Нині ж тут відновлюється життя.
Ресторани та кафе знову відкриваються.
Правоохоронці стежать за дотриманням правил гігієни
та дистанцією між людьми.
Але у деяких містян все ще виникає відчуття,
що все це відновлення відбувається надто швидко.
Мені навіть сьогодні страшно бути на вулиці.
Кафе і ресторани мені здаються переповненими.
Я не знаю, як люди можуть бути такими сміливими,
щоб знову сидіти разом і так близько одне від одного.
Люди мають бути обережнішими, нам потрібно носити маски.
Я думаю, що це все закінчиться швидше, якщо кожен подбає про себе.
Повернувшись на "Гранд-базар", багато власників крамниць
прагнуть налагодити свій бізнес.
Утім, наразі важко сказати, скільки часу ще знадобиться,
аби тут знову стало велелюдно.